at least 215 people have been wounded in
the latest outbreak of violence
in and around the al-aqsa mosque
compound in occupied east jerusalem
[Music]
israeli security forces fired tear gas
and stunned grenades at palestinian
protesters who hurled stones
and other objects in return already
simmering tensions are being further
inflamed by planned march
later on monday by right-wing israeli
nationalists for an event
they call jerusalem day
well they've also been explosions of
stun grenades and tear gas
inside al-aqsa mosque it's understood
that people were staging a sit-in
protest and security forces attempted to
clear them
palestinians said they wanted to guard
the mosque ahead
of the nationalist march well the
palestinian red crescent says its team
is being prevented
from reaching the al aqsa mosque
compounds with aids
88 people have been taken to hospital
live now to harry fawcett he joins us
from there
uh harry we've seen those rather
alarming pictures of the
israeli forces storming the al-aqsa
mosque just talk us through
this morning's events what exactly
happens
well we know that uh there were
thousands of uh people who stayed
in the al-aqsa mosque compound overnight
that is not atypical
in the last days of ramadan that people
from
around palestinian israeli towns and
also from within
east jerusalem will will do that but
obviously at the moment
the state of tension within the old city
and within
occupied east jerusalem more generally
is extremely high
there were obviously a lot of israeli
security forces massed
around the site and something triggered
the uh the events that we're seeing
unfold now the israeli officials israeli
security forces are saying that they uh
came
that there were rocks thrown at israeli
police positions and indeed onto the
road
around uh the old city and that is when
they moved in we've spoken to one
witness who was there at the scene an
activist who says that there were
israeli security forces with uh
rubber-coated
uh steel bullet guns who suddenly
appeared and started firing uh it's not
clear
precisely uh whether they were doing so
after
stone throwing but that is what seems to
have
been the initial moments of what then
turned into an extremely
serious situation in the compound with
police coming in in huge numbers firing
tear gas
especially into the area around the dome
of the rock which is where most
of the female worshipers were we've seen
stun grenades
use of rubber coated steel bullets
injuries to the face
and the eyes of several people at least
eight journalists injured
we've also seen video of uh police
backing people away very aggressively
and in one instance appearing to fire a
rubber coated steel
bullet uh directly at very close range
into the leg of one of the people they
were trying to
disperse also video of people being held
and then being beaten by israeli
security forces
so it's that they're extremely
concerning videos
and also concerning numbers as you say
more than 200 people
injured according to the palestinian red
crescent society they say one of their
own medics
was injured and was in critical
condition as a result of that injury
it doesn't take much for this really to
spin out of control especially
if we start seeing anybody dying from
what took
has taken place so far or what could
take place in the hours ahead
one other concerning video that of a car
being driven by a jewish man just
outside
the walls of the old city in occupied
east jerusalem
he appears to come under attack by
palestinian stone throwers
the car then swerves and knocks one of
them
one of those palestinians over extremely
violently
and then there are further attempts to
throw stones before
they're what appears to be shots fired
by him into the air
it just shows that when people get in
close proximity jews and palestinians
at times like this things can really get
out of control
very quickly they they certainly can
harry how bad do you think this has the
potential to get because
this is all taking place at a time of
heightened tension but also on the
so-called jerusalem day a day which is
uh
quite provocative for many people
living in the city
well yes that's right i mean even when
there aren't that the current level of
tensions jerusalem day as it's known to
israeli jews
is an extremely uh high-pressure event
uh requiring a lot of israeli security
forces
presence and uh putting on the the
palestinian
residents especially of the muslim
quarter of the old city a great deal of
pressure
as well what it commemorates as far as
israelis are concerned
uh is what they call the unification of
jerusalem
in 1967 what for palestinians who live
here represents the beginning
of the israeli occupation in this half
of the city and of course more widely
across the palestinian territories on
this day
the question is whether the israeli
security forces are going to inhibit
at least some of the route of that march
put in restrictions
to prevent close proximity
between jews and palestinians they would
usually march through the muslim quarter
waving flags dancing chanting shouting
banging on
shut muslim owners shops
and if that takes place today then as
we've just seen
already there have been very violent
events that could trigger
even further such events the israeli
police commissioner said as late as
sunday night
that he wanted things to go ahead as
they traditionally do
however there is meant to be a decision
made early monday
we're still waiting to hear the official
decision as to whether they're going to
allow it to go ahead in its
full form whether they're going to place
restrictions in either event
it'll be tense it uh will indeed harry
falsett they're reporting live for us
at the al-aqsa compound thank you harry
for now
well let's stay in occupied east
jerusalem we can
hear now from es abdel razak an advocacy
director for the palestine institute for
public diplomacy
it's good to have you with us here on
the programme
you've been down at the alexa site
just tell us what you've been seeing
hello enes can you hear us in us abdul
raziq
yes hi there uh yeah i was just telling
our viewers that you've been down at the
sites you've been at the
al-aqsa compound give us a sense of what
you've been seeing when you were there
look um we cannot talk about clashes
between two parties or
tensions this is clearly a repression by
heavy armed
occupation force against unarmed
worshippers uh
and people who are just trying to
protest so this is the situation and as
you can see there is a lot of injured
uh we also saw that uh you know the
paramedics
were prevented to access the site uh
there was a clinic that was attacked
also by stun bombs um so it's uh it's
it's dramatic but it's not happening in
a vacuum
it it it's not at all
do you think then that the the israeli
response to to whatever the israeli
forces were responding to
do you think it was is disproportionate
then
israel's response is always
disproportionate we're talking here
about jerusalemites palestinians who
have been repeatedly
told since generations that this city
is for the israelis and the jewish only
they are born with inferior rights
they are constantly under pressure
repressed oppressed
so sometimes it burst and i think it
won't go away even if tomorrow
it doesn't make the headlines in the
media given the um
you know the emperor it's clearly a
problem that will stay because
palestinians
are not you know are denied their
fundamental rights
in this city and the israelis have
emboldened um
the settlers and they are also
emboldened by
constant impunity well there's a clear
sense of injustice there for
people who are um who are living
in this situation but but just in terms
of the visuals now
you're a palestinian how did it make you
feel
when you saw sun grenades
tear gas being fired inside
the the mosque itself one of the holiest
sites
in islam how did that make you feel
you know angry angry but we're not
surprised
because again this is not the first time
it won't be the last time you can see
that the israeli forces they consider
palestinians the palestinians in front
of them as a
security threat as a democratic as a
demographic threat
not as human beings as citizens with
rights
uh you know we are considered a threat
and
i think this is overall what how
israel's system
uh you know functions whether it's the
legislative the
executive or the armed forces uh this is
a system it's a sophisticated system
it's not only
you know just a few policemen uh these
policemen receive orders
and and they uh have been elected and
and trained
um and elected officials have you know
supported
such uh actions so again this is not
comes as a as a surprise this is
uh decades of of uh um
education mentality and political and
policy practices
given this how how do you think the
international community should be
regarding all of this because whenever
there is unrest of this type
there are usually calls for for for calm
on both sides
here and as you pointed out one side
has rocks and and empty bottles the
other side has
rubber rubber bullets and and tear gas
canisters
how do you think the international
community watching these
images she should be responding to this
i mean by starting by reframing that
narrative
we can't continue to both sides uh you
know what's happening
it's not both sides issue there is an
occupier an occupy there's a colonizer
and a colonized
and unfortunately the international
community has not recognized that and so
they're always
making false equivalences and these
false equivalences prevent
us to move forward towards a just future
so the only
solution now is accountability israel
has never been held accountable for its
continuous violations of international
law
and human rights and let's repeat it
what they're doing
in jerusalem whether it's the forced
expulsions
or what they're doing in al-aqsa is war
crimes and it's it can amount to crimes
against humanity
including the crime of apartheid and
this has been analyzed so
the the response should be
accountability and actions because
uh declarations are not enough well
do you think uh palestinians will ever
get this
accountability do you think this will
ever come
yes i'm hopeful and you know
palestinians again they won't go away
and they won't i think back down they
will continue to mobilize
so i i would urge also the media to
you know continue to look when there is
not this outburst of violence because
often and most often uh the violence
of the occupation and the the colonial
aspects of
where we live is you know is is
underlined is is continuous
and is of low intensity but low
intensity doesn't make it to media
headlines
so i think this is there is a root cause
to all of this we need to address the
root causes
without addressing the root causes uh
this this will continue and palestinians
will continue to be killed
and injured and will continue to
mobilize
okay yes abdul razak there joining us
from occupied east jerusalem
thank you so much for joining us on the
program